I think throughout the whole process of
the bachelor I realized I'm really not
that great under pressure and knowing
the typical ending of the show I was
just putting a lot of pressure on myself
to get there when you were told you had
to bachelor no more
Colton Underwood is officially in a
relationship with Cassie Randolph but
they're not engaged the former NFL
player bucked show tradition and skipped
a proposal on his finale while that
works for some people in awhile that's
been the case for the last few years it
wasn't what was best for our
relationship while the lovebirds aren't
engaged yet Colton does know what ring
Cassie wants she's made it know like she
wants to be surprised I know that the
exact ring that she wants so yeah it's
it's all about I know that's it's gonna
be a conversation we have for that
little down the road
that means Colton and Cassie likely
won't use the Neil Lane ring Jimmy
Kimmel gave them for the future proposal
I think you know right now we're just
gonna enjoy dating yeah we just we want
some sort of normalcy of riding bikes
chillin at a grocery store we're looking
forward to doing everyday couple people
who are dating kisses this is a time in
our lives to have some fun and enjoy
being with each other but at the same
time like we are very sure in this like
we yeah we know where we stand we're on
the same page yeah so so if Cassie and
Colton aren't engaged what was this
moment from the season promo all about
today
the biggest day yep that's Colton
standing in a suit staring at a ring box
yeah I mean I obviously my season is
very unique it was different in many
ways you know and there was gonna be a
lot of twists and turns that people
didn't see coming and you know I'm all
about I like to like to troll on social
media a little bit too so I was all for
that you know the fun and games in it
but you know that that was something
that you know we just decided to do
[Music]